bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour chef ou
cet homme soir au lac et qui a touché
deux ballons
nous avons à l'invité vous avez vu et on
est très contente de l'avoir c'est pour
ça qu'on a parlé les deux à la fois
probablement ordre alors il s'agit de
relents de mazères c'est un autre vous
devez connaître parce que c'est un des
plus grands noms de la grande
gastronomie française il est né et
l'exercent son talent au berceau de là
d'une certaine grande gastronomie
française les plus belles c'est à dire
en périgord voilà bien fort bonne chose
il a un restaurant célèbre qui s'appelle
le centenaire relais châteaux relais
gourmand plein d'étoilés et tout ça se
trouve vous ultérieur aux eyzies de
tayac c'est de lire à côté des cavernes
où étaient nos grands ancêtres autant de
cro magnon brevet de l'homme au pays de
leurs usages de l'eau alors vous avez
bien voulu nous rejoindre vous pratiquez
bien entendu et je crois vous l'avez
appris d'abord de votre mère la cuisine
traditionnelle d'abord de votre pays
investisseurs que j'ai réalisé vous avez
réalisé une sûr qu'il faut évoluer
d'inspecteurs et c'est bien pour ça
aussi que nous avons quand même devant
nous des produits qui sont des produits
du terroir et je crois que vous avez
bien voulu apprendre à maïté à la été va
falloir vous appliquez la rue qu'est ce
que vous allez nous faire ou vous
souvenez il va nous le dire
c'est une égale est elle consciente
depuis le cochon au confit d'oie et les
champignons de saison il va falloir
alors il à l'arcade s'applique beaucoup
pour le faire vous avez regardé avec un
aigle mais le tour de mana et et je le
connais je le je veux pas qu'on touche
punk et puis ensuite vous allez nous
faire une recette moi je ne vous dis
rien mais je les ai vus la recette et ça
n'est pas rien alors très regardée
binaire à tout à leur chef à tout à
l'heure à tout à l'heure
qu'est ce qu'il nous faut maigrir mais
là on a la chance d'avoir des produits
excellente dans 17 des girolles du
confit de canard des pieds de portes de
l'ail est un petit peu de persil et des
riders et des feuilles de riz un peu
exotique leurs avoirs pour 80 ou fait on
trouve donc voilà alors que faites vous
en premier eh bien on va mettre les
pieds de fork à cuire parce que c'est
adam de la halle au salé c'est un
bouillon à mouiller la bouillante oui
mais ça le fairway là il est fait le
yoyo mais autrement la voilà fessiers
meilleur dans un brouillard voilà alors
là il faut qu'ils ont moins de trois à
deux heures bien tassés 2h30 3h je crois
il faut enlever surveille on les
surveille et de l'autre côté qu'est ce
que vous allez faire blêmir un ballon de
l'autre côté je vais me mettre dans le
camp le confier à griller du côté de la
peau l'afo sur la pointe voilà l'info
ouais parce qu'il faut que la porte
dorée vous allez voir pourquoi tout à
l'heure
on va laisser dorer et dans les horizons
de temps d'un petit peu
les people sont cuits la pluie trois
heures et on les a déboutés au morceau
dépiauter le camp suite aussi dépiauter
et à notre petit voilà et toutes étaient
ligotés et omar sy bien dorée notre peau
qui se trouve là alors maintenant je
vais prendre un peu de pied de porte je
vais tanner gentiment ici dessus et la
feuille de riz vous l'avez mouillé
mouillé et le mouillé a dû renoncer
c'est la torche et régulier pour
l'assouplir voilà alors là il y en a
c'est une version de ça suffit on prend
délicatement faisant très attention
parce que ça casse
voilà et enfin petits chaussons
voilà et maintenant je vais faire cuire
tout ça dans une poêle avec de l'huile
bien chaudière et maintenant qu'est ce
que vous faites et la galette on a adoré
d'un côté je ne leur aurais de l'autre
par la ligue regardez comme elle est
belle et trois minutes encore et bien là
on va pouvoir préparer de fait la garde
et de la carie sur neuf on les a fait
revenir avec les girolles couper en
lamelles dans huile très chaud 10e ça et
ça n'allait poivrée assez bien entendu
alors que vous faites là il n'y a pas
beaucoup de trac alors je vais y mettre
le bouillon on cuit les pieds de cochon
oui une 2012 ceux des glaces tout ça
regardez comme c'est aujourd'hui
ensuite je prends ma purée d'ail c'est
la purée d'ail on l'avait déjà fait dans
une autre vie y est toujours c'est
comment on l'a fait on essaye et on
mélange je vais m'habiller en tout ça va
aligner plus abandonné watts à ben oui
c'est extra c'est un peu le persil haché
bien fait comment sera le chef
regardez moi ça c'est joli bon j'arrête
m'en veut parce qu'il faut pas que le
persil crise sinon alors je prends la
garniture
je la mets dans mon assiette trop
et là je vais y poser jean kalama
galette dessus
et sur celui de 16,55 landaise qui ne va
rien gâcher du tout et voilà et voit la
veille sa part l'ex imam et retraite
demandé au chef qu'il en pensait bien
l'enfant alors c'est parce que c'est
terminé et jolie ça on va donner un clin
d'oeil supplémentaire du périgord va
donner un petit peu mettre un petit
filet d'huile de noix ça va faire
dégager des parfums voilà
et je vais mettre de la peau course
tronquée des confits de canard dessus et
ne donne pas le cholestérol voilà faux
de dire s'ils perdent ils maintenant que
vous allez nous faire je vais vous faire
un risotto foie gras truffé langoustines
oh la la ronaldo gouard c'est parfait
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut et bien du riz
gros grains de l'oignon de la moelle de
l'ail de la truffe et du foie gras du
périgord mais entendu des langoustines
du parmesan du bouillon de volaille le
fumé de langoustines que nous avons fait
avec les têtes de la crème fraîche qui
sera fouetter et du beurre et du vin
blanc pour mouiller ils vendent
également de graves pour te faire
plaisir maïté pour moi même parce qu'il
est bon alors par quoi allez vous
commencer je vais faire blondir les
oignons et le riz dans une poêle avec de
l'huile bien chaude et comment est ce
que vous voyez qu'il est comme vous
voulez qu'ils soumah et parce qu'il
devient brillant et translucide voiliers
et l'éclaté légèrement là c'est bon donc
on va pouvoir m on va pouvoir mettre
tous les composants maintenance vous
ajoutez c'est à dire un grand deuil pour
parfumer le tout en chemise oui la
moelle qui va rendre tout ça on tue on
tue e et gras
le foie gras ou couper tout petit petit
petit la coupe est un rang benoît sans
grosse brunoise
et la truffe coupé 406 bada qu'est-ce
que tu arrêtes dont tout ça voilà tous
les composants de la base sont dans la
poêle maintenant nous avons plus que
nous n'avons plus qu'à mouiller avec le
vin blanc et puis le liquide et de le
faire cuire pendant 18 minutes 18 ans
arrêtée de tourner sur le feu alors la
voûte et combien de vin blanc la marche
à blanc alors là je vais déglacer avec
10 centilitres de même l'an
grave voilà et on
va tourner jusqu'à absorption
évaporation complète du vin blanc après
quoi nous rajouterons progressivement le
fumé de langoustines et le bouillon de
volaille
dire maintenant le vin blanc et absorber
complètement donc nous allons continuer
la cuisson avec le fumé de langoustines
et le bouillon de volaille
hockey de repartir dans les proportions
de deux tiers de langue de fumée de
langoustines pour un tir de bouillon de
volaille à peu près donc la cuisson dure
18 minutes donc nous allons petit à
petit et incorporé en gros en gros un
litre de liquide pour 200 g de riz que
j'aime une à la fois
bien vous voyez le risotto va être
presque cuit là maintenant on va en
attendant que la cuisson se termine on
va faire cuire nous langoustines à une
poêle très chaude à ce passé avec que de
très chaude on va les faire dorer de
chaque côté pendant quelques secondes
pendant que maïté terminer la cuisson du
riz photo vous venez sera brûlé faut pas
le coup de couteau à la main
il est beau oui oui il allait bien il a
il a tout absorbé pratiquement et on a
plus on va avoir besoin seulement de le
finir avec le parmesan le beurre et la
crème et voilà et se régale et après ça
c'est pas du brûlé non non c'est est-ce
que c'est maïté et riffs
sanofi à sun nador et c'est vraiment
raté qui stagne
donc vous constatez que les langoustines
eux sont bien dorés de chaque côté vous
voyez est bien de ne pas trop les faire
qu il faut juste les faire dorer ça dure
quelques secondes donc je les retire
son mari
et moi je suis toujours à mort y voit là
et maintenant nous allons terminer le
risotto alors qu'est ce qui vous reste à
faire avec ce risotto bien sûr ce
risotto je vais y mettre une noix de
beurre
comme ceux ci
est devenue une noix de beurre
vous remuez maïté oui oui je fais pas
c'est bien tu parmesan a assez
abondamment dans votre poignet et la
crème que nous avons souhaité qui va
terminer toute l'opération
je ne vais pas être à dernier a goûté ça
aide
[Musique]
oui pareil abonde la brouille
abondamment voilà il faut l'inventer
axel il faut la fouetter à vendre ce
sera beaucoup plus beaucoup plus léché
regardez moi ça je laisse toujours le
feu de sous voilà quatre loups je
laissais de feu dessous vous remuez rien
mais vous m'en direz tard c'est le geste
est fort c'est onctueuse et a refusé un
p tit sens et parfumée mais il faut pas
que ça pouvait manquer là son arrière
train de bouillir
saleh n'a plus qu'à le mettre dans le
plat
là il n'y a plus qu à le dresser dans la
voilà
si
vous voulez la luz vous vous là la foule
allouche oui
même si l'arrêt stop à la province a
fait rien vous inquiétez pas
ça c'est un risotto exceptionnel
la food and food et mousse de souffler
voilà
parfait
dispose dessus mais langoustines
comme ceux ci et sa part fait pas bon
appétit tout donne envie de se ruer
dessus eh bien j'espère que vous avez
compris sinon on pourra vous envoyer par
écrit la recette est un jour de fête
essayer parce que ça c'est vraiment
exceptionnel
alors roland mazère merci d'être venu
avec nous on ira vous voir vos esi au
relais châteaux du centenaire pour
goûter d'autres recettes aussi fabuleuse
de celle là oui il est venu avec nous
tout le plaisir sera pour moi merci et
bon appétit merci
[Musique]